[Music]
liz is with us liz is in palm springs hi
liz welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
um so i'm graduating college uh with my
bachelors in psych i'm 23
and i'm graduating this saturday and i'm
kind of
wondering if you like what you think i
should do in terms of i
don't like my home situation i really
really want to move out
but i'm 13 000
in debt um
so i'm not sure if i should tackle my
debt first before moving out or if i
should
get an apartment first um
do you was you have a job lined up
um i'm looking for jobs i have one
that's lined up but the pay is only 20
an hour
okay
how much would you be working
um i'd be working 40 hours a week
yeah
um well i think it's just in 13 000 in
student loans
or it's ten thousand student loans and
three thousand in credit card debt okay
okay
um
yeah i mean i still think to be able to
be out on your own um
for sure as a possibility i mean i would
be looking at your job you need to look
at your budget and figure out okay how
much is going to be your take-home pay
you want to make sure you rent somewhere
that's no more than 25 of your take-home
pay but i would not go buy
a house i would go rent an apartment
but i think it's totally feasible yes
for you um to get out what's the
situation
what makes you want to want to leave
um so we moved him with my brother um
just um stuff happened we moved in my
brother but the thing is that he's
always bringing home girls he's he's
very um kind of verbally abusive to me
and my mom is as well so
i i really want to move out and but the
problem is that if i were to find an
apartment it wouldn't be 25
um just because like rent around here
and even in cities around is like 1 500
for like one person
so i'm
i'm kind of just stuck i don't want to
get an apartment i can't afford but then
i don't want to work like two jobs and
i mean if i have to i will but i just
feel like you have to i can't afford it
you have to
until you get a better job you're going
to be working two or three jobs
right yeah you're broke
and dollars and twenty dollars an hour
doesn't cut it in palm springs
oh no
that's what you're saying and i don't
disagree with you so you may be moving
to a different city too
i mean palm springs is not exactly
cheapville
no
this is like one of the most expensive
areas in the united states
yeah it's not designed for people it's
not the the economics they're not
designed for people that make 20 bucks
an hour
right yeah
so here's the question so there's a
couple of variables here all right
location
the city you live in is a variable
uh your income
what you make per hour
is a variable you found one job at
twenty dollars let's go find one at 40.
let's go find one for 40.
let's use your degree use your psych
degree get into some marketing
get into something use that psych degree
that where it has value where you
understand human nature and you're
plugging in
and the other variable is the amount of
hours you work
and so it probably is that for the next
three years you're going to work a lot
more than 40 hours
and it's there's a possibility you're
doing that in a different city
and there's a possibility a strong
possibility you need to look for a
better job because you haven't found the
best one yet
you can make twenty dollars an hour
stocking shelves at freaking target
so you haven't found the best job yet
okay
agreed
yeah okay yeah
so all of that to combined sets you free
from a toxic situation
hours worked better pay per hour
and a possible geography change to an
area that's more affordable the
combination of those three variables
however you dial them in
uh puts you out in the wild wild west
kiddo you're out here in the big big
girl world now but you're out of the
toxic mess the sewage that is your
family
right yeah and you need to be free from
that don't you
yeah and it's worth 80 hours a week work
for two years to get free from it
right yeah
yeah yeah
that's what the tears are you need some
freedom
but it's scary isn't it
yeah
yeah but here's the thing you needing
this freedom does not mean a fifteen
hundred dollar apartment works on a
twenty dollar an hour forty hour a week
it doesn't that math doesn't work that's
you're trading for one kind of stress
for a new kind of stress if you do that
and the change is going to be heartless
all of that right the the work that's
going to go in that you may not have
wanted or thought about and realizing
that's your reality
maybe getting working jobs that are not
your favorites and moving to maybe a new
city the location piece of that so these
are all big changes
but their possible liz and you can do
this yeah you can do it you're getting
ready to be the most courageous you have
ever been in your life
you're getting ready to have a whole new
level of courage right now that you have
never had before do you have good people
in your life liz are you part of a good
church or do you have good mentors or
friends
um yeah i have um
i just recently made um i reconnected
with my best friend so and she's been a
really good support system for me yeah
that's awesome i would get some good
people around you
um to to i don't want you walking this
alone right because this could be a very
lonely thing um so here's the pain if i
was in your shoes here's the pain i
would choose
i would choose to take a sucky job that
i hate that makes fifty dollars an hour
as long as it's moral and it's legal
okay
all right yeah and because you're not
gonna do it long it's your escape
mechanism
you're going to escape from a little bit
of debt and escape from that house and
get out there and be able to pay your
light bill and put food in the
refrigerator
but you're going to hate what you're
doing for a little while and then your
next step is to find something that
makes 50 an hour that you love
okay
but you're you're going to be making
some courageous
uh
high
levels of change the anxiety associated
with change you're getting ready to
swallow a whole bunch of that
i mean
how old are you liz we were at universal
the other day and we got on this roller
coaster and it went straight up click
click click click i mean straight up we
were on our backs click click click
click click click click click click
click click click click and we know
what's at the end of that right as soon
as that thing gets to the top we're
getting ready to drop off a 15-story
building it was a blast
that's what you're doing right now click
click click click click click click
click you're getting ready to go off
get ready kiddo here it comes
i hope so no it is
it is yeah because it's time you need it
you need it you need to do the brave
wild crazy things that it takes to set
you free don't you
yeah
but don't do this listen you got a
degree in psychology
don't do this while in denial about the
mathematics
okay look at the math the math is your
reality
it's saying
i have to do something different and i
have to work a lot more and i may have
to live somewhere else what's the
scariest part liz what's the what's
still the like
you're gasping what what's the what's
the scariest part for you
well i'm just not sure if i should be
paying off my debt first no or no i'm
just worried no you need to get out and
get a job and get an apartment that you
can afford
okay and then you're gonna save up a
thousand dollar emergency fund that's
gonna be your next goal
and austin will pick up we're gonna give
you a year-long membership to ramsey
plus because that has every dollar the
premium budgeting app once you on a
budget liz and you know exactly once you
get your job you know exactly where your
money's going and your goal is those
four walls your food your shelter
utilities transportation
and then your next savings goal is a
thousand dollar emergency fund then
after that you can look at your debt but
you're going to clean this debt up you
don't have a ton right now you're you're
going to be okay
that's not your problem cut up your
credit cards
cut up your credit cards you're braver
than you think you are kiddo you can do
it you're gonna do it
this is the ramsey show